I call it the toothbrush helmet  what  so my toothbrush helmet is recommended  by zero out of 10 dentists and it  definitely did not revolutionize the  world of Dentistry but it did completely  change my life  since then I've carved out this little  niche for myself on the internet as an  inventor of useless machines because as  we all know the easiest way to be at the  top of your field is to choose a very  small field to me there's a true beauty  of making useless things because it's  this acknowledgment that you don't  always know what the best answer is  and it turns off that voice in your head  that tells you that you know exactly how  the world works and maybe a toothbrush  helmet isn't the answer but at least  you're asking the question